[Music]
the following episode documents the use
of psychedelic drugs which are illegal
in the United States and other countries
while valuable scientific data may be
obtained in controlled studies we do not
advocate the use of these substances
[Music]
this is Iquitos Peru the world's largest
city in accessible by Road the only way
in and out is by air or by river the
Amazon River I'm about to head up the
Amazon to a remote jungle retreat called
Refugio altiplano the refuge on the
higher plane there I will meet with
local shamans to drink an ancient
psychedelic drug ayahuasca ayahuasca
contains dimethyltryptamine DMT a
molecule shaped very similar to
serotonin a neurotransmitter in our
brains ingesting ayahuasca and flooding
the brain with DMT leads to what many
describe as spiritual experiences strong
vivid visions a sense of oneness with
the universe even a sense of oneself
dying but mystical magical language like
that doesn't really seem relevant to
scientific inquiry it could often scare
away those who are scientifically minded
however understanding of the human mind
isn't complete unless it considers
everything the brain is capable of what
does it mean to feel at one with the
universe
why should our brains even be capable of
such a feeling this isn't about having
fun or taking a risk or doing something
extreme I want to learn what my mind is
capable of I'm about to embark on a
journey
[Music]
psychedelics are chemicals that are
structurally similar to
neurotransmitters already used by our
brains when we ingest them they bind the
receptors and alter cognition and
perception in ways we're still trying to
understand when many people think of
psychedelics they think about people
challenging societal norms and
recreational thrill-seekers but that
only attends to a particularly narrow
slice of human history and culture
fossil records cave drawings and
archaeological digs have all provided
evidence that humans have been using
psychedelic compounds for thousands of
years and by used I don't just mean in
the stereotypical drip out sense for
instance among the indigenous peoples of
the Amazon rainforest psychedelics were
and in many places still are a normal
common and totally mainstream experience
as a member of these groups believing
psychedelics can heal give visions of
the future and connect you with deities
is not some weird or new-age idea it's
the way things are but when psychedelics
became associated with certain
counterculture movements the United
States banned research on them in 1970
most other countries followed suit
shortly afterwards
from then on testing on humans was
essentially gone but recently
restrictions have begun to loosen up and
a few researchers have started to
investigate these substances and what
some have described as a psychedelic
Renaissance research universities are
conducting comprehensive studies on the
beneficial effects of psychedelics on
addiction depression and cancer related
trauma by approaching psychedelics
scientifically what we find could
fundamentally transform our
understanding of the human mind
[Music]
when I go to Peru I will be accompanied
by dr. Robin Carhartt Harris one of the
first British researchers in over 40
years to investigate the effects of
psychedelics on the human mind he and
his colleagues have found that
psychedelics don't increase brain
activity as previously thought instead
they decrease activity in certain areas
and the greater the decrease the greater
the reported feelings of what is called
ego dissolution or ego death your ego is
your self-identity it's the part that
separates you from everything else the
part that creates narratives about the
outside world and your story in it when
the ego dissolves your sensations and
feelings don't cease like when you're
unconscious instead your attachment to
your identity does and all that's left
is naked perception eco dissolution is a
concept that I find difficult to wrap my
head around but people who take
psychedelics say that it can be an
extremely frightening experience but
also a profoundly transformative one one
that makes them feel more connected to
others and to nature now I knew that I
might feel ego dissolution on ayahuasca
so to make sure I was ready I decided to
speak to some experts
before setting off to Peru dr. Carhart
Harris traveled from Imperial College
London to meet with me this will be one
of the first times that anyone has
scanned a healthy person's brain with
fMRI before and after ayahuasca yeah
it's quite pioneering work really the
thing that's on my mind right now is
intention yeah I've heard you should
know why you're drinking ayahuasca yeah
I would suggest that you think about an
emotional intention to make it emotional
there's a lot more frightening to me
yeah partly I think I'm I'm quite happy
and I don't want to ruin that right I
don't want to drink ayahuasca and then
think oh my gosh I'm not close enough to
my mom mmm or I don't show my wife I
appreciate her enough and now I just
feel terrible there's something to be
said for sitting with those thoughts
be mindful right and in so doing they
become less of a threat you look them in
the eye and all of a sudden they reveal
things to you and they're scariness
seems to dissipate I hope I can embrace
that while I'm surrounded by people who
were all filming me you know yeah the
most important thing is that intention
to go in you dive in in and don't resist
you don't resist yeah I think that'll
really be important while I'm on the
trip Robert has arranged for me to have
a number of scientific tests in order to
measure brain activity behavioral
differences and physiological changes to
my brain today we are scanning micro
strain with functional magnetic
resonance imaging or fMRI this allows us
to see the whole brain and how different
parts connect and talk to one another
this way we can compare how Michaels
brain may change before his experience
with ayahuasca - after the ayahuasca
experience
I expect to see that one network of the
brain that relates to introspection will
become more strongly connected after the
ayahuasca
[Music]
after meeting Robin I still felt some
trepidation about my trip but with my
pre ayahuasca fMRI completed it was time
to go to Peru the trip to the Refugio
altiplano retreat involved a flight to
Lima Peru a second flight to Iquitos
Peru followed by a 90 minute boat ride
of the Amazon River it was a long
journey and every minute I got closer
meant it was that much harder to turn
back
the Refugio altiplano retreat is in a
remote area of the Amazon rainforest
in the northern part of the Peru it
would be an authentic setting for my
ayahuasca experience so Kelly what does
the word ayahuasca mean ayahuasca means
the vine of the soul ayahuasca has been
used for possibly over 4,000 years and
shamanic rituals and is the primary
plant medicine for healing in the
villages with the ayahuasca ceremony
just hours away
I met with Jose the shaman who would be
my guide during this experience
hola Jose EMU estan gusto a pleasure
lieutenant Sokka it's my pleasure
welcome to the poetic black bottom where
many people come to look for change in
their lives Jose how do you feel about
someone like me coming in who is not
part of your culture taking part in it
in a way that might not come from the
same history but I mean me when I do it
for me there's no difference and for the
medicine it makes no difference this
medicine
all it wants is to make your life better
and heal you on the very first night
with our guests we give them a very
small medicinal dose to see how each
person is gonna react differently to the
medicine and then tomorrow night we'll
dial it up a little bit it was great to
speak with Jose about what the ceremony
will entail I am nervous about the
emotional part of it and I'm nervous
about the visions and feeling like I've
been disconnected from the real world
scientists know very little about how
ayahuasca works since its illegal status
in many countries makes it difficult to
study we do know that it's key
ingredient is dimethyltryptamine or DMT
which is a hallucinogen thought to occur
naturally in the human brain in small
amounts
DMT can create psychoactive effects by
acting on certain receptors in the brain
but normally DMT is broken down rapidly
by enzymes in the brain however
ayahuasca is actually a brew made from
two plants one contains DMT and the
second contains a chemical inhibitor
that blocks our body's ability to break
down DMT allowing the effects to last
for hours dr. Carhart Harris gave me a
series of tests to compare how I changed
during this experience given that we're
in Peru were in the jungle and you're
drinking ayahuasca it has authenticity
that perhaps sometimes you lose when you
give psychedelics in the laboratory
environment yeah because we're going to
be doing this after you drink ayahuasca
we need a control condition so what I'm
going to do now is I'll ask you a short
list of questions about your journey
here and I want you to rate how you feel
about these questions on a scale here we
have zero to nine nine will be strongly
agree and zero will be strongly disagree
so I learned more from my journey here
to this retreat center about how past
events have influenced my present
behavior
I got ideas during that two five six
with different psychedelic drugs to
ayahuasca like LSD and psilocybin also
DMT we found some quite consistent
changes in brain activity we've seen
that the brain activity is richer and
more varied of course we can't will a
MRI scanner up into the jungle
so the eg set up that we have is pretty
much the best possibility that we have
to do this according to Jose this flower
bath would protect me from bad spirits
during the ceremony reow I didn't
believe in such things but I was glad to
do it because it was a symbol of Jose's
good intentions
[Music]
hola buenas noches the initial smaller
dose ceremony was expected to last about
two hours with the effects beginning
after about 30 minutes we'll begin with
their ceremony tonight asking God to
guide us to give us knowledge and
intelligence we're gonna bless the
medicine first
[Music]
the ayahuasca tasted earthy women maybe
also a bit like fennel or something it's
hard to say I never tasted anything like
it after swallowing at all my heart
started racing
it was the most nervous I would be all
night DMT from the ayahuasca was flowing
into my blood and brain there was no
going back
throughout the ceremony shaman Jose sang
icaros
or chants which were meant to guide me
through my spiritual experience
[Music]
the initial dose was meant to gently
introduce me to ayahuasca the effects
began slowly and were mild I began to
feel as though the room were swinging
like a cradle I was aware that the
motion wasn't really happening but it
made me feel sick and nervously
off-balance nonetheless my imagination
was more vivid images in my mind were
more detailed but almost always under my
control
the ceremony ends when the shaman lights
a candle I was comforted by this because
it was a sign that the effects would
only be weakening from here Thank You
Jose neither were two moments where
actually was a surprised by something
that I saw one was like a very vivid
like bamboo that had been cut so that it
was at a slant and I remember going wow
where did that come from but as soon as
I did it was gone one of the effects of
ayahuasca is to kind of create a sort of
chaos in the cortex that can lead to
dreamlike visions the second time I was
like oh yeah nature and like do I feel
more at one with everything and I
imagined trees but only in this ring and
then all of a sudden they came really
close and they were all right here in my
head but I was like I did not think that
I didn't intend for that to happen I
think a good comparison for what I felt
last night if you in a sober state of
mind just imagine something like think
of a pink elephant
okay now an image probably popped into
your mind but not like a super detailed
one if I asked you a specific question
like how many wrinkles are on its trunk
you'd have to probably imagine it again
and then like basically fill in that
detail but under the effects of
ayahuasca those details were already in
these these imagined images they seemed
only as real as an imagined image as a
daydream but they came with more detail
and a few times I'd say maybe three or
four times things appeared that I did
not feel like I had put there
but as soon as I was aware of that they
disappeared
I'd like to look at the Stars yeah let's
do that
the morning after my initial dose of
ayahuasca my head was clearer and I
wanted to discuss my experience with
shaman Jose you've had a perfect
introduction ceremony emotionally and
sort of personally the only sort of
revelations I had was that I was
probably more worried than I needed to
be beforehand and then I'd let that
affect my behavior and now I'm not as
dominated by what might happen or what
has happened I'm just kind of in this
moment right now like I feel much more
open to mystical thinking yes demo
system must completely he recommends
that you complete with more medicine
tonight so that these will help you
complete the insight into yourself last
night I had a third of a cup esta noche
a third isn't worth of three quarters
will be those for tonight three quarters
okay
it's weird my I had an intention going
in I experienced this is a very
interesting scientific endeavor but I'm
fascinated by how I want it to have
meaning I feel like I didn't hit that
oneness yet tonight might be different
Mike was getting the high dose tonight
and the experience is very likely to
differ quite substantially from the dose
that he had last night
I'm interested in personal development I
know that that's a big part of ayahuasca
for a lot of people I'm open to it for
sure
but I do feel still some apprehension
for a larger dose tonight
hey Michael I'm here to pick you up for
ceremony
- noches
the higher dose ceremony was expected to
last for hours with stronger and more
vivid hallucinations
[Music]
josè smoked a cigar made of a tobacco
plant that's indigenous to the Amazon
called lapacho the smoke is believed to
clean the energy fields of the body and
remove negativity from the ceremonial
lodge the second ceremony included
another shaman Daniel who drank and
sprayed floral water
[Music]
I started to see he's very geometric
bright squares like stacked like Aztec
pyramids moving and I was traveling down
through these like repeating kind of you
know fractal images of everything too
many things to really describe music
notes and colors and shapes and squares
then I started to feel like oh my gosh
this is going faster and faster this is
too fast and it hasn't even been that
long and then I felt my body being
covered with these blocks and I like saw
my body from above and felt like I was
disappearing
and that's what my heart started racing
and I said mmm this was very bad this is
not good a lot of emotions I always have
were amplified so loudly I couldn't
ignore them and I had to come up with
ways to console myself so that I
wouldn't be consumed by them and have a
complete breakdown and panic attack and
I resisted and I successfully brought
myself back to calmness just by saying
I'm fine I'm not going to die and
everyone here can help
the visions were really really vivid
they didn't feel like they were under my
controls it really felt like they were
just there a note from the the song
would occur and it would cause this
image and that was pretty frightening
because I I wasn't I was like on a ride
that I didn't know the
[Music]
Robin yeah I can do the EEG now yes sure
I spent a lot of the ceremony being
anxious about having to do this tests
with Robin I don't know how to deal with
the lights coming back on and Robin
talking to me and asking me questions
but the more I concentrated on why I
feel anxious the more I realized it was
just about me it was about how I felt
but then I said I'm here to do a show
we're filming this Robin wants this data
everyone will be happier if I do it so
I'll just tell Robin I'll try my best
and that gave me the courage to do it so
being less selfish basically saved me
from panic attack each time I read an
item if you could give me a number
according to how you see yourself at
this moment okay I see myself right now
as extroverted enthusiastic okay this is
a big change for Michael usually he's
very extroverted and on his pre
ayahuasca answer he gave a higher number
extroverted enthusiastic five but now
I'm seeing signs of withdrawal and
introversion from him I see myself right
now as critical quarrelsome
to see myself right now as critical
quarrelsome six the experience has led
to a change him how he sees himself it's
in a way reflective perhaps of a higher
waking state it's interesting to already
see those changes and it's only halfway
through the ceremony shaman Daniel sang
in Shipibo an indigenous language spoken
by only five thousand people in the
world I'd always been frustrated by the
difficulty people have explaining what
it feels like to have a psychedelic
experience and now I know why it's a
different state of mind and trying to
describe it is like trying to describe
anger to someone who has never felt it
or what colors are like to a blind
person
[Music]
oh man I'd say about five minutes into
that first song I really panicked my
heart rate picked up and I actually
touched my chest to make sure it wasn't
beating as fast as I thought it was but
that moment I may have left my body or
something near it before I stopped I was
very scared that I was disappearing
Michael was describing what to me sounds
like quintessential ego dissolution the
start of it that feeling that he's
disappearing that his control over his
mind and his body is ceding entirely and
he felt some resistance to that with a
high enough dose you just forced into
that space my feeling is that the
intensity of his experience was just
short of of that kind of profound
transformative type experience I think
he got a bit of that but I don't think
he was all the way I was there in that
ego dissolving state for a moment and it
terrified me I wish I'd been able to
surrender more fully but I definitely
got a good taste of it
so the dosage last night was much higher
yes
visions the the visuals were were really
vivid and the feeling of strangeness was
really strong I'd be curious to know
what Jose was doing last night what was
he reacting to that he saw in me what
plants did he call forth and why would
they need glad okay stylist Bobby you
were going through an intense ceremony
it was strong for you he said he was
very happy because he knew this was
gonna have a positive ending for you I'm
really interested in in what the lessons
were I felt so small and so humble but
but honestly I liked it I wasn't afraid
of it I was glad to be reminded that I'm
weak I feel like the experience
amplified everything I'm concerned about
way above what would be a normal amount
to care about it but that made my fear
and anxiety big enough that I could
actually relax them the question is will
I remember to apply that or will this
kind of stay in the jungle before
leaving Peru I completed one last round
of tests with Robin now place this ahead
in order to gather data after my higher
dose of ayahuasca
thank you so much thank you I can't wait
to see you back in LA and see what other
thoughts you've had with these tests
being here in the jungle is more organic
the cost of that I feel that I've
collected data that's gonna tell us
something important and meaningful about
how psychedelics and ayahuasca
specifically work on the mind in the
brain
after returning home to Los Angeles I
had my second MRI so that Robin could
see if there were any changes although
my ego dissolved only for a brief few
moments I was teetering on that edge
throughout the entire ceremony and I was
anxious to see what it looked like in my
brain
Robin welcome to my home thank you for
coming back I can't wait to see what
results you got yeah how did ayahuasca
affect my brain okay so we found
something quite interesting we found
that your brain activity became more
complex more diverse more rich more
varied under the ayahuasca than baseline
what does it mean to have more complex
brain activity in terms of how I
experience things I think we can
understand it in terms of the richness
of your of your imagination of your
ideas trains of thought can be more
varied more changeable more dynamic I
definitely experienced that yeah all
right you looked not just at my brain
through the surface but you went deep
inside yeah what did you notice there he
looks at a particular brain network
called a default mode Network that seems
to relate to our sense of self or ego
we've seen in other studies that during
a psychedelic experience that network is
dramatically compromised it shows a kind
of disintegrate and actually that
process relates quite strongly to
people's ego dissolution and yet after
the experience the network comes back as
a kind of reset or a kind of rebooting
of the network and what we found in your
brain after ayahuasca as predicted was
that your brain reset the network became
more cohesive more integrated more
strongly connected within itself Wow
yeah you know afterwards I really did
feel much more preoccupied with my
identity and my past my future yeah you
asked me a lot of questions before and
after about my insight into experiences
yeah how did those compare well actually
we saw something really nice in those
data so your ratings of insight for the
journey the lower dose and then the
higher dose with ayahuasca and what we
saw was that there was a graded increase
in your levels of insight or your score
at baseline was 27 after the low dose
experience it was 39 after the high dose
serum
it was 49 yeah I definitely felt the the
larger the ayahuasca dose the more I
considered and learned about myself
yeah well Robin I'm glad that we were
able to do such a you know in the
environment type study so thank you for
coming all the way out to Peru with me I
really appreciate it I hope that I
helped it's been a great experience in
I've learned a lot
as I look back on it now I feel like my
experience with ayahuasca was one of
resistance instead of surrendering
myself to its effects I dipped in and
then got scared and I told myself it'll
be all right I'm not going to die but I
should have just gone in and through
that said I learned a lot about how to
control anxiety that relinquishing
control and selfishness can make it
vanish but perhaps in doing so I lost
the chance to experience my mind
operating without the controls and
dampening I'm so used to that I'm more
comfortable with scientists like Robin
have managed to break through tight
legal restrictions surrounding these
substances and have begun to find out
what they can teach us about the mind
their findings so far are just the
beginning of our understanding of these
powerful compounds which shows us how
much we have yet to learn about the mind
and brain and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]